yes wonderful I think we're rolling
awesome so hi welcome back to the box
this is deluxe 2013 and I'm here with a
Knick to talk about Android hi from a
design perspective is that the right
word design yeah absolutely like how
what is to be an Android app how you
design an Android app to kind of look as
well as like work like you expect an
Android app sorry so UX is the word part
and the rest is taste and colors that
are you saying there's one way to build
apps only ah no I'd say there's many
ways you can build an app but i'd say
there's certain things you can do to
make your app work like an android app
is expected to work so that your users
will know how to use it and they'll know
how to navigate around the content
within it the look and feel the
aesthetic qualities like colors certain
interaction patterns those can be
customized like to bring your own
personality to your application so if
you look at you know a variety of
applications out there look at something
like the expedia wrap to the google play
music application it was the food like
the alarm clock application like they
look very very different they all have
their own feel to them but they follow
certain rules so an interaction patterns
and touch target presentation themes
which means that when a user picks it up
they'll know how to use it right so that
that's absolutely key so um I'm an
Android developer ah should I also be
the designer does that even make sense
if you want to do both if you can do
both then awesome like a more power to
you I enjoy doing both it depends really
like if you if you're working on a big
project and you can have a dedicated
design resource that's awesome and I
think a lot of the most polished
applications I like that if you're a
one-man band who is just kind of like a
developer interested in design then
hopefully there's a lot of resources we
putting out there that you can get up to
speed so things like the Android design
guidelines which have been around for
about a year now and have kind of
progressively got more and more we're
actually upgrading those with the
releases of right right right with each
release and as each new pattern so every
now and then such as when the navigation
drawer gained popularity we started
documenting it and saying we
think this is the best way you can use
this pattern add adaptive design site
and as well as the show that I do once a
month or so called Android design in
action which is all about how to design
for Android so hopefully were putting
the resources out there that if you're a
developer who's interested in design
that you can get up to speed so how hard
is it to start I mean there's the
Android design guidelines do you need to
read all of it and implement all of it
or you have it all wrong or is there a
way like you don't have like a too high
of a bar to start with yeah it's my
favorite thing about the Android design
guidelines is how short they are like
it's not a massive tome of human
interface guidelines written in very dry
language that is a you know hard to get
through you can actually read the entire
site in about half an hour 45 minutes it
we're all a huge amount of content so I
would recommend yeah read it like this
is the basis of what it is to be an
Android application like how you should
should operate so I'd say it's a great
start to read that and then go from
there so then go from you know to
there's a flourishing community of
people out there talking about Android
design so particularly on Google+ which
is where I see most of the chatter
having as well as other places like
dribble and other places I think android
design conversation is really picking up
so what kind of reward can I develop
expect from actually having followed the
this guideline spent the time actually
designing this may be on the Play Store
with users and interacting with them
beside actually make a difference can
you actually see you know changes and
then apps that have gone from you know
default design to something worth it's
more more oh absolutely thoroughly like
11 case study that becomes the mind is a
pocket they're going to read a letter
application they didn't exercise where
users were misunderstanding their
archive feature and they changed the
user interface to kind of follow our up
paradigm we have the button on the top
left to take you up within the app and
they change archive to an action on the
right which is where users are expecting
it they sort of some crazy increase like
seven hundred percent more use of the
feature or what understanding of the
picture so there is definitely you know
a lot of benefit to an individual app
the overall goal are following the
Android design is hopefully a better
application right so the process of
going through and thinking about your
design and improving it and like you
know standing on the shoulders of all
the hard work gone into the Android
design patterns
should make your application better so
we do see a lot of you know comments and
feedback from users like that you know
apps which are nicely designed tend to
have a higher rating as well as on the
google play store there's obviously
things like the top lists and as well as
things like editor's choice or even
there's a collection of applications
called the beautiful design and
application list core collection I guess
so you can't get into those kind of
things without having you know and there
should be good inspiration if you look
at those this I mean if they got there
right probably if you get do something
similar yeah if you're looking for
inspiration go to the beautiful design
collection this google for android
google play beautiful design and you'll
get this collection and these are some
of the applications that Google Play
recognizes as some of the best in class
good so we've just released android for
darfur KitKat that change anything to
the design guidelines cat for me is a
maturing of the design guidelines so I
think that means a small strange though
exactly I don't think we've radically
changed direction but we've refined all
over the place it's all about polishing
it's all about delivering a better
experience so color like we touched on
earlier on we backed away from having
these kind of very very strong accent
colors so by default the user interface
used to use a lot of this kind of like
you know blued it was kind of like jolt
of contrast in your application and it
didn't particularly leave a lot of room
for your app to have its own personality
because if you or you know your color
was like your branding was red for
example you have all these like blue
stop controls in there it can be quite
quite clashing actually so what we try
to do the OS is back that away so by
default you'll get more of a neutral
experience but the reason is to leave
room for apps to innovate so an app can
then express its own personality can
then customize on top of that so things
like that i think is showing a maturing
of the platform so the platform is kind
of getting out the way to let the apps
really shine great and then would you
recommend people actually changing
anything at this point though fork if
cat specifically or is it you know just
more choice for those that then and more
way to express themselves if needed yeah
well there are some other features as
well which I'm quite excited about so
one thing I'm really excited about for
designers is in the immersive mode yeah
you now get now you now get access to
the entire screen so if you have these
on-screen buttons you can outdraw
behind them or hide them temporarily or
persistently so that you know unleashes
a whole new kind of interaction modes I
think if you look at google play books
for example which is a beautiful job of
like hiding all the system chrome and
getting other way and really focusing on
the experience of reading and then
coming back and making it really really
easy to navigate again when you need to
I think those are the kind of
opportunities that KitKat provides for
designers and developers to kind of have
a really rich interface ok cool so
before we close um you know I have a nap
on the play swords doing ok I have a 3x
something breathing which is not bad but
I want to improve that design guidelines
is where I go is there this one trick
with give me that one flip to switch to
get a better design ok so i would say
the one thing you can really do is focus
on your information hierarchy i think
the one thing that people i know is
they're going to coming from a developer
background i'm really excited to dive
into app and create it and i use the
latest you know buttons and libraries
and so on but i think the biggest
benefit you can get in designing is it
could really think about the information
hierarchy and use that to create your
navigation so that it makes you out
easier to navigate around i think the
kind of the visual stuff can add a lot
on top but if the if the fundamental
kind of information hierarchy isn't
there then you know you need to start
from from the beginning so I'd say yeah
look at information hierarchy then look
at on navigation and interaction
patterns and use that and then once you
kind of there then apply the visual
stuff and the one top tip one thing that
really bugs me of applications is touch
feedback just make sure you do that
properly as well it's like the simplest
thing but if an application doesn't
respond when I touch it then it feels
slow it feels laggy feels buggy so
that's my one top tip for sewing you
should be doing second top to top tips
is use Google play's beater
functionality as well if you're playing
with this stuff you know it's a great
great opportunity to use the beta
testing factual remind what that is yeah
exactly so you can create a community or
a Google Groups mailing list and have
people opt-in to say hey I've got a
higher attitude for risk I'd like to
play the latest shiniest features and
before people and give you more feedback
without the expectation of it being you
know a stable production release
so if you're doing these kind of
refinements you can like push them to a
smaller slightly more kind of a less
risk-averse kind of group and get
feedback from them quite quickly without
having to distribute to like all your
hundreds of thousands of millions of
users great awesome thanks for the tips
and Android design guidelines on the
Android there are no sauce it's a
pleasure yeah check out the Android
design guidelines at
developer.android.com / design and
follow Android design in action at
Android design in action calm all right
do it thank you awesome see okay